[Music]
all right welcome everybody so today
we're doing a lecture on some of my
greatest losses for me it's was
necessarily actually my best quality
losses I mean very rarely - a losses end
up good quality but for me I think good
losses are instructive losses and losses
from which we could all learn from
including myself going forward so
today's lecture we're gonna focus on the
games that I mostly lost because of lack
of sense of danger and allowing my
opponent too much initiative and leaving
my pieces not completely developed as
you guys you'll see even for me as a GM
that could sometimes be an issue and you
know no matter how good you are you can
never neglect that part of the game
following the basic principles so this
is a game I played at the u.s.
championship against the Grand Master
Alex only shook you know very famous
Grand Master Hall of Famer it's one I
use championship before very strong
Grand Master I was black in this game I
played the Slav defense
and he played Queen b3 trying to attack
both my pawns and I played Queen c7
indirectly defending the d5 pawn because
of the bishop hanging so Knight c3 is
six-nine f3 knight c6 and now my
opponent realizes that okay he has to
play for something otherwise I'll just
go h6 Knight f6 Bishop e7 comfortably
develops so he goes night h4 to try to
go for my bishop pair at least trying to
get something so I play Bishop b4 that
way if he takes I want to leave his
Knight stranded so he played Bishop d2 I
went here he took right so can hear my
opponent played a very interesting
ambitious move t5 it's a porn sac but it
leads to very interesting play which I
wasn't able to handle in this game so I
took the porn now he cannot take back of
course because of the night hanging and
if he takes again I go back but he goes
Knight a5 that was his idea all along
with two threats
okay so I go a night of five I go g6 and
he goes back so if he takes he helps me
develop he didn't want to do that and
after this he can go castles which is
also okay for black so he played 94 he's
taking advantage of the fact that I've
weakened myself a little bit and now
this pawn is kind of weak as well I
played Queen d7 which is certainly an
okay move although here I could have
already started thinking about trying to
develop my pieces but Queen g7 was maybe
okay there is also possibility of takes
takes Queen d6 takes giving up some
points but taking on b2 and now I have
some initiative of course he doesn't
have to take on b7 but this way of
playing would have been interesting it
would have avoided a lot of problems
that I had later in the game I play
Queen d7 it's still not a bad move this
should be five Bishop f6 so of course I
would love to go here but then he's
applying too much pressure on my c6 born
and I'm gonna lose the pawn back and
it's gonna be a bit trouble for me
so I played this move with the idea of
getting the Knight to e7 but now he
played a good move Bishop c3 which
prevents my Knight from going to e7
because then Knight 66 is a winning
tactic for white like if I take he just
takes I lose the Queen sorry I don't
lose the Queen but I my rook then hangs
so it wasn't working
so I played the move so here I think a
six would have been a safest bet in
getting rid of that Bishop getting rid
of the pin and if Bishop a4 I can meet
it would be five and if Bishop takes c6
I could meet it would takes and then I
can develop 97 next move where he
doesn't have Knight 66 anymore
with all those tactics and that would
have been a sensible thing to do get rid
of the pin and just make sure that I
find a way to develop quickly the move I
played though is a little bit too slow
it's a to move idea I play King f8 I
wanna go King g7 and then 97 but that's
a little bit too slow because I'm still
kind of leaving my pieces undeveloped
and he has time to do stuff so here he
castled and yeah and and in this
position what do you think black should
do here
oh yeah
97 I think doesn't work tactically
because what are you gonna do after yeah
so still doesn't work so I ended up
playing King g7 but King g7 ran into a
little bit of trouble yes yeah
I'll just push it takes
um Knight takes d4 simply Knight takes
d4 yeah because if Bishop takes before I
go Queen D 6 and then King g7 and I
trade off the bishops and if Queen 8/3
Queenie 7 this should be 4 I just go
tonight X be 5 and I get 3 pieces for
the Queen
so I would be totally fine here Bishop
takes Knight takes I would be fine
so I didn't do that he played king
cheese but I played King g7 and now
white played a good move f3 opening up
that rook and I remember I missed that
move when I when I was playing the game
I remember that move came as a surprise
to me I thought I will be able to just
complete my development everything will
be ok but again that's what you know
good players do when you're behind on
material let's say down a pawn but you
have a lead in development you have to
play very energetically you have to
really play for initiative and try to
you know as quickly as you can open up
the game to try to disturb the harmony
and try to not let black consolidate
otherwise if you give me a couple of
moves I'll be better I'll get up a paw
and I'll be fine but he found this good
move f3 so now I took that because I
don't wanna do this because then I'll
have problems dealing with this at some
point in a lot of positions for example
after this now there's this so so then
f3 came 964 864 he doesn't want to take
with the bishop because then he ends up
trading the bishops off ultimately so he
took with the pawn but still it's not
easy for me so I played Queen d6 I my
Queens attacked take stakes
now he maybe could have played a little
bit better maybe woke up to was better
than his move but he played a logical
move bringing his last piece into the
game Roque you won and now it was my
chance to to sort of get back in the
game here so who can tell us what should
blog do in this position
this [ __ ] XD for check I'm afraid that
will be a little bit dangerous
let's see say go here
I mean I guess you could try Knight of 6
but yeah I roam do you want for example
yeah so I don't think that well this is
a check but after King H won the
problems I can also do this intermediate
move so you can't even yes I don't think
much 64 works yeah
which one
yeah a six was the move to play and then
after Bishop c4 or something then I done
a thing could be five I miss just
thought I had some analysis here where
where did it'll go maybe didn't save
yeah I think it's b5 [ __ ] takes up
seven and then Bishop takes d4 yeah yes
that was it I needed to get the bishop
out yeah I needed to get the bishop to
have seven actually it's all the counter
and Tudor I needed to force him to take
my pawn but then the bishop is kind of
in a way of his harmony and then I can
take and then I can somehow survive with
Knight of 6 like maybe I can do this and
then this and then I can sort of survive
here but okay this was hard to find so
as you could see like I have a lot of
practical difficulties here but I played
rook c8 and he took the pawn and now I
played rook c7 okay so I'm trying to
somehow guard the f7 pawn that's why I
played Roxy aatrox g7 but it's too slow
he goes bishop before now he's not even
down a pawn and he has a huge lead in
development and here I decided to go for
it and grab the pawn but now this is
just lost for me king h1 basically I was
playing too many moves with that with my
knight and g8 and rook on h8 and were
never that Hagins up happening it
usually doesn't lead to good things it
usually means that you have to be played
very very precise just to survive
but you can't really think of being
better you have to play very very
carefully so I needed to avoid the
scenario that's why I think my king of
fate King g7 was way too slow given what
my knight was not developed I needed a
six so that get the bishop to stake on
c6 immediate or than 97 or I needed to
play a little bit more carefully earlier
but I could not have allowed my post
Knight to be on g8 like that
so Queen b6 and now okay he fee missed
the very nice win actually so I'll give
you a chance to see if you can find it
he found a prosaic way to win but there
was a much nicer shot here for white
that he missed yes what wish to f8 I
think I'm taking that right yeah
any other ideas yes
our rocky eight um I think I can play
night of six a defense
yeah the move was very nice it's a to
move tactic you know it's your your
right your look you should be targeting
the F H square in some ways but you need
to find you have to look for all your
checks captures and and threats it's a
nice little tactical idea for white yes
very good very good
Adi right rookies six yes and this is a
killer because after this this is
checkmate
and after this Bishop f8 so this is what
can happen if your pieces are not
developed he didn't find that he played
the rock takes d4 also winning and then
Bishop c3 and then I had to take that
takes Queen d6
now it takes here and then he transposed
into an endgame which is also probably
winning but okay I think he could have
won easier
I hear he's gonna win all my pawns and
I'm still in very bad yeah here she
found a nice little fine ass he played
rook f7 you know just you know
emphasizing the fact that I cannot
develop my pieces like if he at least if
you got my if I was able to get this in
somehow an unlucky eight drove d8 I mean
even though I'll be down a couple of
points I maybe have some slight chances
of surviving but he never gave me that
chance he played rogue f7 was nice
smooth keeping my nights like this and
this was just like a symbolizing game in
that way but not my night on Jade and
rook on h8 never got in the game because
until it was too late
okay so rook f8 and finally I had to
work very hard to bring the King back
just to but now I'm losing all my pawns
under very bad circumstances and finally
the night somehow gets in but this end
game is of course totally hopeless down
to pawns and eventually he converted
that
I'll show you a couple of more moves but
here I resigned I mean the Portland Sea
file is just push Cygnet there's nothing
I can do of course down two points yeah
so that was a US Championship game
against ownership which you know I knew
it was gonna be a fighting game but of
course I was hoping it would go a bit
better now I'm gonna show you another
interesting fighting game I had this is
against an Indian player Karthikeyan he
he is only he was only 25 30 feet at
that time but this was the last strong
game of a London tournament which sadly
lost it which was a little bit annoying
at the time but to give him credit my
opponent played a very very well does
cam and he took advantage of my slightly
awkward displacement and played very
nicely with the initiative by the way
this guy I don't feel as bad about
losing to him now because this guy beat
with Sheila Graham Maxime in Gibraltar
last round in this year and scored 8 out
of 10 in Gibraltar getting clear second
behind I think it was Artemyev so like
in such a strong tournament eight out of
ten is like winning a tournament so
definitely very strong Blair how was
black and this was a French
and he played him interesting move 94
the idea of that move is that if he goes
Knight of 3 he didn't want me to go
Bishop before check and now see three he
can take I can take on c3 take on c3
take on c3 and then take on d4 so that's
the idea of 94 he's trying to prevent
that to the doctor this I just he just
goes c3 it was think it was interesting
improvisation over the board so I
decided to play move Bishop d7 now this
I would say was one of the reasons that
I lost the game because I put this
Bishop on d7 but this Bishop kind of
restricts my knight and the problem with
this move is that even when he plays a
neutral move my goal was to go knight c6
but the problem is I'm not really
threatening this move because he goes 95
so I still can't really continue my
development so this move was a little
bit illogical and it obstructed my
development and as you'll see later on
this visit was a problem for me a lot
tactically so that's why it's important
to in a very beginning try to develop in
the most natural way try to just
complete your development in the most
logical way I do want to go Bishop e7 I
thought he'll go queen g4 but thing is I
can go King f8 or even castle here and I
was afraid of Bishop h6 but okay Bishop
f6 is not so bad with my pieces are
normally placed I would be fine but I
put my brush up on d7 it was a little
bit of one of these moments where I over
complicated things over analysed okay so
he played c3 possibly Bishop c4 was even
better but c3 is okay and now I realized
I don't want to go knight c6 anymore
because of 95 although I maybe I can
still play Queen b8 and be fine but I
decided to play Bishop e7 now I thought
Bishop d7 c3 will be in my favor
but it turns out it wasn't so he played
Queen g4 principled move I castled he
developed a Bishop to h6 like I expected
I played Bishop f6
and he castled and in this position I
thought that my opponent blundered or at
least I thought I thought my position is
very good so I played the move Bishop e5
and here it looks like he's in very very
big trouble because it looks like I'm
threatening of five this is protected
and I mean what is he gonna do about
that the problem though is that his
development is actually better than mine
so you see we're both castled but yes
two knights developed a bishop I have
okay also Knight Bishop Bishop developed
but it's his move and as you see my
Queen side is still not fully developed
so he's definitely not behind on
development I would say he's probably
slightly ahead because it's his move and
he does have one more piece developed
than I do and you know you can't really
call my Bishop on g7 being developed so
what do you guys think whites should do
here in this position
oh yeah white yeah yes yeah you have to
play a four because if you don't play a
four you know you're just going to lose
the thing is though amazingly enough
despite all the opportunities I have in
the position position is actually not so
clear I mean and here I thought for a
while so okay so I started with the move
ninety three and I thought oh this is
like fantastic I mean now I'm forking
his rook and the Queen the problem
though is that I'm not really developing
new pieces without now ff5 Queen g3
would have happened and then I'm not
really doing anything tactically wise
because if he takes this I'd see if I
take that he takes here and now there's
a mate threat so I cannot take the
knight if he takes I take there's again
I made threat so I'm not winning
material with f5 Queen g3 so I played 93
and now he played Queen g3 I mean the
Queen h3 sir Queen g3 would have the
more natural move would have been met by
it takes takes and the night of five and
now my Queens being attacked
I mean his Queens being attacked sorry
and the white is losing so he played
Queen h3 Bishop takes d4 rook takes d4
Knight of five and here I thought okay
still everything is in control and I'm
gonna win material here but even despite
the fact that you know I'm winning
material somehow white is doing very
well because he still has a very big
lead in development basically the rope
got more into the game and I traded off
some of my developed pieces
I helped his rook develop even more now
he goes Bishop g5 again with a temple
attacking my queen I played f6
and he just went back route d2 and then
I had this position in front of me and I
thought about this position for like
ages I mean at this point I had like one
hour and my opponent had something like
ten minutes left so it was clear he was
a little bit improvising but his
intuition somehow in this game was very
good that he was always gonna be fine
and indeed the engine later showed that
White's doing very well here but I was
like sitting here and thinking how on
earth do I get an advantage because I
thought like so many like his Bishop is
hanging and I thought somehow I should
be doing well but then the more I
started looking at lines the more I
realized it's not so clear and I spend
like more than 30 minutes here and I
ended up choosing the best move Queen c7
well the problem again is my pieces are
not coordinated this 27th is not very
well placed and my rook and a knight
this time on the Queen side are not
properly developed and that's why my
position even though I'm winning
material the tactics are not really
working in my favor
for example if F takes G five you know
965 h6
you can take that take that and then you
can play move like Bishop d3 and
materially it's roughly equal but I mean
if anyone's better it's him he has all
this initiative and my pieces are still
not in the game my queen side so it's
kind of a problem so what to do so I
thought about some other moves but then
I realized that he is also too just
threatening g4 so and then you know
maybe sacrifice on f6 and go g5 and just
completely crash through on the Kings
side ultimately so I played the move
Queen c7 with the idea of at least
getting the Queen off of some pins and
also add pressure here
all right so now we need to continue
energetically with white so white played
g4 keeps going for it so I took on g5
now what do you think a white would do
if 97 is played
how does white continue his attack yes
mistakes of 6g takes of 6
yes very good just continue that
initiative and again I looked at that I
was analyzing her I didn't like it and
indeed it was kind of busted for me I
mean not see really I'm okay but my
pieces are not developed so temporarily
he's kind of up material and he's not
gonna give me a couple of moves to
consolidate so I play takes he took and
I took here he took this and I played G
for I think if this move I think he 7
was a problem and then some Queen e6
sent some tactics there so he played g4
and I played g4 he played Queen h4 and I
took that but now he just completes his
development and now you again you could
see that he's able to develop all of
these new pieces he still has an attack
and I still can't quite develop my
pieces because of too many threats so
it's a big problem for me
so I played Bishop g5 trying to pin that
night to the rook and now here we go
Knight of 6 starting for the nice
attacking combination attacking plan and
this move I just did not see Knight of 6
I thought of some other moves for him
but Knight of 6 I didn't see but it
works my pieces are and again the thing
is he does not have to calculate at all
like ahead of time like air all the
lines he just can intuitive the feel
that why it's much better because all
his pieces get into the game and my
Queens side is not playing and I don't
have time to get it in the game
and now king of seven is met by queen
age five with a continued attack
so basically King g7 rookie one rookie
six but now White has a crushing attack
and the rest is kind of agony I was
playing on because he was very long time
but the problem is he is only down one
piece for like for a porn but his attack
is just too strong my king is now not
safe and so finally I gave up a rook to
get my night out but of course that
wasn't gonna save me either and here I
resigned because of King all moves up
then rookie to end and now I'm down a
queen so once again you know last time
against only sugar was the Kings side
against the this guy was the queen side
so you see how if you play a little bit
awkwardly in the beginning you know
especially if you're black you can end
up stuck in a situation like this where
you you're not able to complete your
development even when you want so that's
so it's so important in the very very
beginning to really pay attention to
that because if you're playing a good
player who's very energetic good with
initiative you know they can really
punish you and the last game that really
got to me in that regards it was a game
I played against Liang go wonder and I
was actually here in st. Louis chess
club it was not at the US Championship
it was in one of the classics and after
I lost that game I remember I wanted to
quit chess because it was a very painful
game you know because I thought you know
he was only 14 years old at that time
only an international master like he was
killing everybody in that tournament
think it was like he after this game he
had five and oh and I remember that game
like I I had a very tough drug in the
day before where I blew a completely
winning possession and then I really
came back to try to fight hard and at a
wonder game like I really came to play
you know focused I felt like I really am
did my best and then I got demolished
like this and I felt like if this is if
you know if this is gonna be my best
then I have no hope in chess I was
thinking you know at least not at the
elite level and I thought okay if not
the elite level then I might as well do
something else coach or whatever so
that's kind of one of these turning
point games for me where I just you know
really got discouraged but then as I
thought more about that game I realized
that well the reason I lost that game
was it was the past same pattern
it was just continued lack of sense of
danger and I realized I have to just pay
attention to that much more in my games
and then I you know ever since that game
I don't remember you know the next time
I lost quite this kind of way so at
least I was happy and then actually I
have won a game because of someone else
another GM kind of violating some
principles which I was happy about of
course I cannot show that game here
because its losses but maybe some other
time but in any event this game against
the Wonder it's actually a very
instructive game from a lot of
standpoint of you I show to all my
students now it's great instructive game
so in the gate in this game I'm black I
wonder Liang at that time fortune rolled
international master but about to become
a Grand Master now he's like you know a
constant fixture in the US Championships
always winning the huge juniors
so we played the opening and in this
game he decided to sacrifice a point for
the initiative and I took it which is
certainly fine so now we have a normal
position where you know he has a lead in
development and I have an extra point so
the position is dynamically equal here
so question to you guys is what plan
would you choose here as black and and
why this is a this is where I made a
mistake and this is where a lot of
people make mistakes
yes
Bishop c5 okay let's say play room t1
mm-hmm
23
which would sway
or Quinn said Bishop g5 kingside Rogue
d7 well you have to Castle queenside but
I don't know you're gonna be down and
exchanged here and okay I don't think
you I mean my rooks are gonna be pretty
active and I mean that's just the first
thing that comes to mind but maybe there
is something else besides that there
could be this idea at all
don't know if that quite works I think
Bishop c5 is a bit loose don't you think
because my route gets to d1 quickly and
you know I can start bothering that
Queen ninety-five does get rid of the
wish her parents a very tempting move I
would have loved to play that but it
runs into a tactical problem Bishop
takes c6 and in fact every knight move
runs into a tactical problem 95 there's
bish takes c6 tonight of six same thing
I mean I would love to play one of these
moves but I can't and I mean it's like I
wanted to play those moves so much that
I played a move rook c8 defending that
c6 pawn and then trying to go Knights e5
or Knight of 6 but the problem with that
move with it's too clumsy the rook c8
it's like one of these Bishop d7 moves
in the previous game rook c8 it stares
at that point okay it does one function
but it really it's all it does but the
rook is kind of stupid there and as
you'll see later I ran into tactics
because of that rook so it's kind of
violated some logical principles so it
would have been much better in a
position like that
to just focus on completing the
development but it's not easy because he
wants to play room t1 so that's why the
main problem in this position is the
Queen so let's just get the Queen out of
here to b6 where it defends this you get
out of a temple and then you just simply
want to play Knight of six Bishop e7
castles and black really has no problems
I mean white has compensation you know
but a white will never be you know
better in this position I can also have
played rogue d8 with the same idea and
then let's say if after Rudy ate a frog
do you want and play Queen f6
and a 95 might make at some point sense
but also just Bishop e7 and again you
know everything would have been okay but
but I played rook c8 okay the move is
not terrible but it kind of was a
prelude to my problems later on in this
game
sir um do you want and now I played
queen of six of course I cannot take
this react because of rugby one but I
actually dare to take that porn later
and as you'll see that was quite a big
problem
so queen of six he played I played now
in this position his best options
probably queen g3 and then some
initiative with Bishop c2 because i cant
castle yet because of this move now it's
quite subtle though he played rocky one
which is also kind of natural but now i
actually I'm in this position I'm doing
okay I played Knight c5 which is the
move I always wanted to play
he played Queen g3 now and in this
position you know normally I should just
simply go bridge to e7 sure I lose the
pawn with Bishop e5 but after Queens g5
I don't really have any problems okay I
will lose the pawn back but it will just
be some equal to end game and as long as
I complete my development I should be
okay what I was thinking this I thought
my knight and c5 defense to be seventh
one and so now I said well why can't I
just take on b2 I mean I didn't see a
clear effort and I thought wow if I can
win the point b2 and get away with it I
might just you know win the game I'm up
to pawns and I was like really in a
fighting mood and like I was just under
estimating the danger what I should have
done instead is if I didn't see him a
problem with Windex B - I should have
told miss of war myself this move is
totally not logical like look at the
quality of his pieces and look at the
quality of my pieces like my pieces are
not developed my King isn't open
the game is open his pieces are all
playing and yet I'm decentralizing my
queen or going all the way on b2 and
then taking this pawn I mean something
must be wrong here now I might not see
what exactly is it but this is the only
kind of kind of move it's okay to play
if I've thought about it for like 30
minutes to 45 minutes and really worked
hard to look for opponents ideas here
and still couldn't find it okay then you
should trust yourself and you know if
you don't see it you play it but to play
it in like five seven minutes of
thinking that's not good enough I mean
whenever you play a move that you feel
is a little sketchy you really have to
make sure you think quite deeply about
it at the very least and I would say if
it's like a quicker game you should just
intuitively avoid playing such a move
you know just going going based on
general logical principles because again
you can't drew the calculate everything
in every position you have to just go
based on general field so now my
opponent played a nice move Bishop f5
and basically this is a move I missed
well rather maybe I saw that move but I
thought that I can just get away with
Queen f6 and I thought I will be doing
okay here after Queen f6
but it turns out from like move back I
missed that in this position a White has
a very powerful resource yeah
Bishop e5 is okay but then I that I
thought I was prepared against I thought
I'll go Knight takes e4 and then I think
I calculated rook takes e4 Queen takes
e2 and I think if Queens e3 I can even
go Knight c5 also so I thought I can be
fine here after Bishop e5 but that's why
he played Bishop f5 he save guard the
bishop and he still has the Bishop e5
idea and I thought now I can bring the
Queen back but it turns out I can't
because White has now tactical
possibility
what is Bishop where Bishop g5 queen
takes yes very good very simple tactical
idea so and there we go that is my rook
on c8 hahaha
I told you that will let itself know it
just seems like whenever you do
something a little bit awkward it always
lets itself know later on in the game it
just finds a way to like rear its ugly
head you know that's why it's very
important to follow logical principles
in chess so I had to you know take on a
two to try to almost like safeguard e6
but of course it's not a move I wanted
to play at this point I already knew one
I'm it's very dangerous but I was still
hoping that maybe I'll somehow survive
but he was very good with the initiative
so he played Bishop d6
you know that's trying to remove my main
defender of a lot of key squares so I
played Queen a5 he took on c5 and
another idea was to remove the guard
because you guess that he wants to do
this takes takes okay so now what to do
well he can I can play king of seven or
Bishop e7 if king of seven and Queen b3
is kind of a problem I mean I looked a
little bit at Queen b5 but then check
here Queen f3 h6 check I didn't see this
whole line but this line just
demonstrates that it's bad
for block and the queen bee to to defend
mate I believe this
check check check me check here so
there's a mating attack in every case
here so that didn't work I mean III
played in Bishop e7 already more
intuitively and now he played rook de 1
which is okay but it does blow a big
part of his advantage now I'm sure the
move he wanted to play was rookie 5 now
the idea is you know if the Queen moves
and then you can start going C 3 and
then Queen takes g7 and then he just has
a very big attack here so I was gonna
actually Castle here and I was thinking
this if this this you know now I'm
threatening here I can go to cap 7 but
see really it's actually not so bad for
me I have woken them I have woken the
bishop for the Queen and I have also a
pawn so I thought I have a good chance
to hold the draw here at least somehow
but in this position I think what we
both missed is that there's a brilliant
move rook d7 he doesn't take the Queen
right away but you go through d7 first
and then I have nothing better anyway to
take on then take to take on e5 but then
I'm giving up a queen under much worse
circumstances and this is probably
technically lost
so instead my opponent Pedro q1 and here
I made a mistake so it was a
miscalculation I thought I'm surviving
after castles but it turns out I'm not
if I would have seen what was waiting
for me after I Castle like it's like I
wanted to finally castle but it was I
didn't see deep enough that I'm losing
so I could have played rook f8 or even
g6 and I was afraid of positions like
this but of course here like I'm out of
the immediate danger and I think I have
very good chances to draw here
ultimately but in the game I played
castles rookie 7 rook f7 and here's the
critical position the final big critical
position of the game
how does white win here find a force to
win here so I'll give you guys some time
like a few minutes try to find the
forced win
I thought I'm fine here still I thought
it's like I saw some ways I can get a
worse position but nothing that you know
I thought I'll lose like in five moves
but it turns out I action I'm losing in
five moves here four moves action
ah yes I've added
yeah queen bee fries you know of course
I that's like one of the first moves I
saw but then I can take enough - did you
see that king each one yes but you know
even still yours you have a nice threat
here rook e8 but I can still you know
kind of successful I think defend
against it
rook f8 for example taken up seven I can
take Queen takes because Queen e1 rook
f1 huh
white wins but I take enough seven yeah
I mean I could that's number one I can
take enough to number two I can also go
Quincy five I can block your queen and
they get again there's it might be an
advantage but there is no force to win
at least black is surviving so Queen b3
I saw that move it's certainly very
tempting but it doesn't quite win like I
would have been happy if you played
Queen b3 but he plays something else
here
yeah
Loki a Czech takes takes look a fate
again very tempting based on this idea
sure you got in fell in love with this
idea but 25 again and again you could be
a pop or maybe but you know I have very
good drawing chances so that Quincy five
ideas so you need to find a variation
where you at least get rid of immediate
twenty five you know that's kind of the
first step of the equation you have to
notice the Quincy v ID and then find a
way to kind of prevent it
addy what do you think
rook 1e5 well rookie 25 I think I can
even do Quint xe7
so and then takes takes a plus it's I
mean I have other possibilities maybe as
well quit support but Queenie 7 I think
I'll be better than so again find the
line where at least you get rid of the
Queen g5 defense in the beginning you
know again sometimes you know I'm not
saying Queen b3 is the wrong idea you
sometimes you have to just whenever you
see a tactic in one way you have to
sometimes look for a transposition of
the move water yes
rook f7 first very good king of seven
now it will be three yeah because of
Queen t5 now we have this so at least we
got rid of twenty five that's already a
very big accomplishment now I have to go
quick King f8 so now we're already
looking at something now this was all
ready we can go Queen b7 at the very
least but here we have something much
better than Queen takes B cell find a
way to win yes rook where it - Oh III
look III years I mean that's possible
I'll go Queen d5 Doe
yeah queen b7 rook to e8 again White has
a very big advantage here but at least
black is survived for a little bit and
maybe it's not totally lost at least
even though it's pretty close to lost
but there's a way to win the game like
in a way that you know I have to resign
in like two moves like there's basically
two move idea here that really just
finishes the game completely Queen e6
very good excellent Queen six and then
the rook has to move to d8 probably and
now rookie five very good with the
temple because it's still not too late
to mess up rook here here Queen d6 black
is better suddenly check but rookie five
does the job and that is lost and now I
have to lose the Queen or get made it I
chose as a good sport to get made it
usually you know if my opponent plays a
great game and he has an attack going
like this I usually let them make me in
such stations I mean I don't I don't
play till made in a composed endgame or
something like that but I you know would
let them meet me in the middle game like
this if but during game I was fine but
after the game I was so upset you know
you can't imagine you know I gave it
like such a good effort and then like I
worked harder than I ever do during game
but maybe psychologically I had
something a wrong approach Knight took
too much of my shoulders I don't know it
was one of these just very bad games for
me and but again the good news for us is
now we have more material to learn from
and you know now it's like that game is
history it's more than two years ago and
now we can just laugh about it but
certainly at that time it was very very
unpleasant alright we still have a
little bit of time left so I'll show you
my game against Fabi which and that was
a total disaster that was
that was an embarrassment now was like
that was one of the games that I lost to
him in 2018
u.s. championship in round two and in
case some of you followed that year I
lost that game in like less than two
hours it's like embarrassing to play in
a year's championship and to lose the
game to ours but it was just one of
these days when nothing was working for
me I didn't
I got ran I ran and so like an opening
line that I didn't know I was just not
feeling that great that day I over
prepared I you know I was just not fresh
and I was just not seeing things very
well that day and it was just a bad
combination it was just a bad game I
want to forget as soon as possible but
still something to learn from in this
game I'm black and I gave the French
defense a very bad name unfortunately in
this game so sorry to you guys who play
French no French is actually a much
better opening than I gave it credit in
this game so here I decided to play the
you know I think it's called the Blues
variation or something like that
Queen a4 I actually remember I prepared
this opening specifically for the US
Championship when I thought I had
analyzed it well but then my opponent
came up with a surprise idea h4 and it
turns out he read something on some new
and chef's
article or or maybe it was not new in
chess but some other magazine and he saw
that the ideas interesting and he didn't
even he said he didn't even analyze
deeply but he said okay let's just play
it he decided oh during the game the
thing is I the reason I wanted to play
this line is because I know that Fabi
beat Narad Itsuki Daniel Nordisk is
stronger a master in the previous year's
year's championship and I had an
improvement over that game so I thought
maybe I'll get the chance to get that in
and then I'll get a good position but of
course Fabia's very well prepared player
he knew that and he decided to deviate
first which was very smart and
unfortunately I was not well prepared
for it now
if you are dealt for the surprise in the
opening the best thing to do is just try
to again follow general logical
principles and then usually things will
be kind of okay so in this position what
would make sense is well we know in the
French v6 Bishop a6 is a very logical
idea but the thing is the night on the
night on g8 probably needs to be
developed almost no matter what right
you cannot play with night and g8 and
it's not gonna go to h6 because you know
it's too weakening like this so 97 is
the move I would need to play no matter
what at some point right whereas knight
on c6 could wait because maybe after b6
[ __ ] 6 the night might want to go
to d7 or even a 6 so just from this
standpoint of you logical principle
being flexible don't declare your
intentions it would have been much
better to start with this move
instead of played this it seems like I
kind of got unnerved
he played h5 so ok he wants to play h6
and weakened my dark squares so I played
h6 and he played Queen D once so the
idea was he pushed a pawn up the board
he made my King moved to f8 and now he
can move the Queen back to guard some of
his weaknesses so in a game I took on g4
now this move was already kind of very
risky again I'm behind in development
and Here I am grabbing the ones in the
center it would have been much more
sensible for me to play b6 and then
again trade of the bishops although here
already it's not as good of a version
for me with the knight on c6 but it
still would be kind of acceptable for me
instead of that I went for pawn grabbing
and then I went for pouring grabbing
again thought I mean I have an extra
pawn and everything will be kind of okay
but then suddenly in this position I
realized I'm in quite deep trouble
because White has a very not very subtle
threat here what is White's threat here
in this position
yeah
rock h4 so if I play b6 rock h4 would
trap my queen in the in a very funny way
well okay I can play t4 but okay that's
kind of pathetic and then I'm giving up
a porn and still have lots of problems
and then the rook is gonna come over to
t8 so this is gonna be lost so I ended
up playing I didn't want to go night b8
or something and then go Queen d7 I
thought this would be way too awkward
passive so I ended up deciding to play
g5 with the idea of stopping rook h4 and
after this Queenie 4 and bringing the
Queen here but of course that was very
very sketchy
suspicious to say the least because now
my king is even weaker even though my
Queens kind of doing ok it's still gonna
always be under attack and my opponent
played a pretty smart move okay he just
goes Queen d2 getting the Queen in the
game I played 97 and Bishop d3 and here
okay I mean normally I just go Queen g7
I'm still much worse but I'm surviving
but here's some how my brain was just
completely not working and I thought
I'll take on g2 you know porn grabbing
figuring of game I thought he was gonna
go takes and then I was gonna take take
Queen g7 and maybe I'm doing much worse
but at least I'm not losing right away
but I completely forgot that my opponent
could just go King it - it was just one
of these days that I was not seeing
anything
and then he connects his other roken
suddenly I have I mean my queen is
threatening to be trapped again and you
know I played queen g4 so I'm hoping to
go here or something he goes here then
he goes there and the rest is as you can
probably guess will not end up well
technically I'm up to pawns but okay who
cares about two pawns in such a position
he played rukka 4 of course I can take
with check but then I lose my queen the
Queen gets trapped
so he goes ninety-seven bishop before
pinning me there a five now he takes
this and and here I resigned I'm if I've
fallen into a double pin and now I'm
gonna lose massive material so at this
point I knew you know enough is enough
so again you know what it comes down to
is you know following basic principles
development you know it comes down to
sometimes very the basics you know and
as you could see even for me as a GM
once in a while he'll gaff I'll have
games that you know I violate these
principles and that should give you guys
all hope that if you're playing a higher
rated that just because they do
something sketchy doesn't mean what
they're doing is good sometimes they can
also play very bad chess if a
grandmaster can play very bad chess once
in a while you know you're 2100 opponent
or whatever 1800 opponent was ha times
high-rated can also sometimes do bad
things and you have to make sure you
trust yourself not your opponent you
have to trust your chest education trust
your judgment and don't you know believe
your opponent if he does something that
you haven't seen it necessarily and
that's the key thing you know you gotta
believe in yourself if you want to
become a better chess player that's
without that it's very hard and yeah I
hope do you guys have any questions from
young on today's lecture
well bah i suggest after you have a big
loss like that how do you shake it off
um okay so the game against the Indian
guy was the last the question was how do
you shake off a tough loss
you know after yeah so well the loss to
the Indian player was the last strong
game so obviously there was no time to
recover in that tournament but I had to
just you know some time to recover after
that tournament then it was go on to the
next term and play that term doesn't
nothing happened the lost of a beam it
was easy to overcome in a way because I
thought okay if I might as well play my
worst game of the tournament that might
as well be against Fabi with black a
game that I might lose potentially
anyway so if this is the game I'm gonna
play horribly might as well be this one
just you know get it out of my system
it's a quick game now I have a chance to
arrest and in some ways losing a game
like that is easier to handle then you
know tough loss where you play for five
hours and still lose you spend old
energy then you're tired for the next
game a little bit and then you still end
up losing so in a way a loss like that
was very easy to shake off just like as
if it just didn't happen to completely
wash it away and then play the next from
now on the terminus of nothing captain
so this loss with Fabi was easy to shake
off the loss against a wanderer was
probably the toughest for me because it
was kind of like in the middle of the
tournament and I was trying to be the
Wunder to get back in the tournament to
fight for first place and after this I
knew that I can't really realistically
fight the first place anymore and you
know it was just like a helpless feeling
out actually there was a rest day right
after that it was just kind of like yeah
it's like I it was very hard to actually
you know play the rest of the tournament
I managed to finish ok I think I got
third place or something in that
tournament but that loss was very kind
of it like it would it hit me deeply
sore speak you know the wonder game so
some losses are certainly harder than
others and oneisha gamer was early in
the tournament you know in a u.s.
championship I started like slowly half
out of three but I remember I'd actually
took that loss pretty well I thought
okay I got outplayed he'd played better
I mean he he understood some things you
know better than me and I kind of also
was able to so I'm in the I mean over
the years I've learned to a think handle
learn to shake off and hand the losses
better than I did in the past I think
one of the things that helps is not
being overly obsessed with the result
but instead the short-term result I mean
and stead focusing in the process I
think the most important thing the most
important way to view a bad result you
know whether it's a loss or especially a
tournament bad tournament is like a
wake-up call so if you feel like you're
not not not doing something that you're
supposed to and then you have a bad
result then okay great it's a wake up
call then that means you have to just
start doing the things that you're
supposed to be doing to improve on your
game now if it's a bad result where you
don't even know what you did wrong then
if you have a coach then maybe they can
help you you know try to analyze and
what went wrong or it could be something
just like one of these situations where
once in awhile we could just have a bad
result as a test like possibly it's
because like in the past we'd haven't
handled a bad result in a good way and
life is sending us the test again to see
if we this time can handle a bad result
with more dignity that's what I always
tell all my students because I know that
it's happened to me a lot of times like
whenever I did not handle a loss at a
certain critical moment in a good way I
know that I might have to deal with that
test again like to deal with an
unpleasant loss so then I know that I
better deal with the loss in a good way
because otherwise I'll keep getting
tested and certainly that test is not
pleasant it's like you know when we were
in school when we were in school let's
say or when we are in school if we fail
a test or fail a class we need to retake
it so same thing in life you know when
we fail a life test usually we have to
take it again
so I mean now I'll tell you one story
which i think is kind of relevant I
remember when I was a younger player
younger GM I had this habit of whenever
things did not go my way my way I just
didn't really want to fight the rest of
the tournament when it was had nothing
to play for even though there's always
something to play for you can always
learn from any game every game but I
just didn't really want to hear that and
at some point I was going through a
slide and then I had another like one of
these bad tournaments and then I just
decided I told myself you know what this
last round I'm gonna play it like it's
my most important game ever in my life
even though I was not playing for
anything anyway I mean slate no mining
and on stake you know I was already
gonna lose rating it was gonna be a bad
tournament but I still decided that my
regimen before that game and my focus
during that game will be as much as if
it's like the most important game of my
life and I was very happy to actually
finish that tournament off in a good
note I played a very good game in our
last round and then ever since that
moment it's been like over a year since
since that tournament that I've had to
play like for them for a meaningless
game and I've gained over like 100
points ever since that moment so
sometimes you know when you pass a live
test things can really start clicking
for you like in an unexpected way so you
have to just try to analyze like why the
bad result happen try to think about
what you can do better if you can't
think of then you can ask a coach and
sometimes you can just be like a
circumstance of something you did in the
past but as long as you're truly
studying in the right way and you know
that and then you have to just have
faith that at some point things will
turn around so you know I guess you know
that's it's a long answer but I think
it's adequate
[Music]
you
you